[Musique]
mais l'année sur les athlètes vous allez
porter pour les couleurs la france lors
de ces deux zones de vos exploits nous
ont délivré un important beaucoup de
joie de bonheur à des millions de
français
séduits par ces moments de joie
nous le devons à une certaine idée du
score c'est aussi notre courage
détermination et raymond rahme le
travail quotidien qui vous a amené à
l'excellence c'est aussi le résultat
d'un effort collectif l'avons souhaité
et mister que le sénat puisse apporter
sa contribution en recruter en
apprentissage et sportive de haut niveau
pour les accompagner dans la classe
politique et gildas
rappel du site c'est aussi un hommage
nous voulons rendre à tous ceux qui nous
ont entraînés kochi libe le fait de
retrouver cette volonté ce matin un
ensemble de c'est vraiment parce que
derrière cette célébration hier
naissance dans des fosses éléments ardue
ce qu'on attend en fait en tant que
sportif s'était senti soutenu d'avoir
une place dans la société parce qu'on
reste des sports amateurs mais au final
avec le soutien des pouvoirs publics est
avec ses dynamisme de parler de 1024 on
va arriver à faire quelque chose de
grand c'est toujours intéressant de voir
que les pouvoirs publics se mobilisent
pour le sport et on a la chance d'avoir
les jeux olympiques et paralympiques
dans deux ans toute cette mobilisation
depuis quelques années ben c'est plutôt
une bonne chose mais j'espère surtout
que ça va continuer après 2024
[Musique]
d'une nation et la poser
sir qui l'a motivé après les futurs
élèves un ralenti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]